THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH -- THEM A
WELCOME EVERYONE HERE WILL MAKE
A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM -- I KNOW
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE SO ALSO
SIMULTANEOUSLY ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND I BELIEVE
INSURANCE COMMITTEES ALSO GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
THE FIRST OF ALL IF FOURTEEN
AGENDA ITEMS WE ARE NOT HEARING
FOR ITEMS THAT ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB ONE SIXTY SIX ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY SIX I
AND NUMBER.
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN FOUR AND
I AND NUMBER ELEVEN A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO I'M ALSO
GOING TO HEAR.
IN SPECIAL ORDER ITEM NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY TEN FOURTEEN FIRST
BECAUSE WE HAD HEARD THAT BILL
PRIOR AND WE WILL JUST FOCUS OUR
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE HERE
JUST ON THE PROPOSED.
AMENDMENTS INSTEAD BILL THERE
WILL BE A FOUR ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES NOT ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT I AND NUMBER TWELVE A. B.
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO I NEVER.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHTEEN OH TWO
AND ITEM OF FOURTEEN A. B. --
EIGHTEEN OH THREE SO AFTER WHO
AND THEN WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL
HAVE TO SEE.
I'M WILL HAVE THE PRESENTATIONS
AND THEN WILL ACTUALLY RECESS
UNTIL THE CONCLUSION OF BUDGET
COMMITTEE SO WITH THAT SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN PAN HERE STONE.
DORADO DORADO HERE GROVE HER
TADO.
THE TOTAL HERE LEYVA LEYVA HERE
MITCHELL MONNING MONNING HERE
RUBIO.
WE HAVE FIVE OKAY WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION. ONE WEEK.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- IS -- YES IS A
MEMBER OF DONALD.
PLEASE COME UP.
HERE ITEM FIRST ITEM NUMBER --
TEN AND THE FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR WE WE
FIRST WE'VE HEARD YOUR BILL A
LAST YEAR APPRECIATE YOU WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE I KNOW YOU
ACCEPTED THE PRIOR MEN AND STORE
SOME ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION HERE
WAS THE THOUGHT THAT AND STAND
YOU TAKING.
SOME ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS --
AND WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS SINCE
WE RE TALK ABOUT THE BILLING
CHIEF WE ARE GOING TO FOCUS ANY
QUESTIONS OR DISCUSSION WE HAVE
JUST ON THE ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THAT WERE ACCEPTED.
BY THE AUTHOR OF LOS YOU'LL TELL
ME WHAT THE ACCEPTED THEM OR NOT.
YES THE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS. TO TEN FOURTEEN
WHICH ADDRESSES SEVERAL OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE COMMITTEE
IN LAST WEEK'S HEARING.
MY PRIORITY HAS ALWAYS BEEN
CENTERED ON THE CLOSURE
HOSPITALS AND EMERGENCY ROOMS
AND THE IMPACT IT HAS ON A
COMMUNITY.
AS SUCH THESE AMENDMENTS RETAIN
THE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY TO A
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS ONLY FOR
HOSPITAL CLOSURES AND EMERGENCY.
DEPARTMENT REDUCTIONS.
I HAVE A GOOD CREE TO COMPLETELY
STRIKE SECTION TWO OF THE BILL.
WHICH EFFECTIVELY REMOVES ALL
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS ON
DOWNGRADES OR CHANGES ON RELATED
TO EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THESE MEMBERS ALSO REDUCE THE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
ELIMINATION OF A SUPPLEMENTAL
SERVICE FROM ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS TO NINETY DAYS.
A SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICES
SOMETHING LIKE A BURN UNIT I
NICK YOU PICK YOU OR SOME OTHER
SERVERS THAT IS BEYOND THE BASIC
SERVICES HOSPITALS ARE REQUIRED.
TO PROVIDE.
AGAIN THIS NINETY DAY NOTICE
REQUIREMENT WOULD ONLY APPLY TO
THE COMPLETE ELIMINATION OF A
SERVICE.
NOT A REDUCTION OR DOWNGRADE.
LASTLY THESE AMENDMENTS CREATE A
NOTICE EXEMPTION FOR CLOSURES OR
SERVICE ELIMINATIONS DUE TO
NATIONAL DEBT DISASTER OR THE
STATE EMERGENCY.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND A STAFFER WORKING CLOSELY
WITH.
SO AND THE SPONSOR ON CRAFTING
THESE AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE THEY
REPRESENT A FAIR COMPROMISE ON
SEVERAL OF THE ISSUES WE
DISCUSSED LAST WEEK.
MAKE A BRIEF STATEMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THESE AMENDMENTS IS
STEPHANIE ROBERSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
MISTER CHAIR [inaudible]
THANK.
REMEMBER SEVENTY REPRESENT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION PROUD SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL.
COMING CONSULTATION WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL FOR
MOVING THIS BILL FOR US I JUST
WANNA MAKE A QUICK STATEMENT ON
DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE POINT
THE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN TAKEN WE
TOOK FURTHER AMENDMENTS IN THE
PAST HEARING THAT WE THOUGHT
SATISFY CONCERNS.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT IT'S
VERY DEVASTATING WHEN HOSPITALS
CLOSE AND MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
WHEN HOSPITALS CLOSE THOSE
SERVICES ARE NOT REPLACED WE
KNOW THIS FOR A FACT.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE.
THAT NOTICES HOSPITALS CLOSURES
TO COMMUNITIES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND OTHERS IN THE EVENT THAT A
HOSPITAL PUT CLOSES SO WE CAN.
POTENTIALLY BY SOME TIME TO GET
ANOTHER OPERATOR AND THAT'S ALL
THIS BILL DOES HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH TEMPORARY.
WORKERS WERE HAPPY TO ENGAGE ON
THAT ISSUE IF IF IF MEMBERS SO
DESIRE TO TO DEAL WITH THAT THAT
IS NOT ABOUT THIS BILL IT'S A
SIMPLE NOTICED.
BECAUSE WE ALL BELIEVE THAT
THESE ARE BEACONS IN THE
COMMUNITY IN THE NEXT SEISMIC
EVENT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE HOSPITALS ARE OPEN AND WE
WOULD ASSUME.
THAT MEMBERS WILL WANT TO KNOW
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER TO HAVE
A PREPARED PLAN TO HAVE A
WORKPLACE SAFETY PLAN TO HAVE.
A AN EMPLOYER PLAN IN PLACE AND
SO THAT'S ALL THIS BILL DOES NOT
HAPPEN TO ENTERTAIN ANY
CONVERSATIONS OR QUESTIONS BUT
WE WOULD HOPE DATA.
THIS BILL MOVES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHER WILL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MONEY TO THE CORD.
OKAY ONE MORE SUPPORT FOR GUESTS
PLEASE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
ARE A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON CATHERINE CISCO THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE TRULY APPRECIATE THE WORK ON
THE AMENDMENTS RELATED TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICES AS WELL AS
THE ADDITIONAL DECREASE IN TIME
RELATED TO THE SUB MODEL
SERVICES -- I THINK ARE A
RESIDUAL CONCERNS ARE RELATED TO
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS -- ON
THE FINANCIAL RELATED TO FOR
HOSPITALS ARE CLOSING FOR
FINANCIAL PURPOSES I THINK WE
CAN CONTINUE TO TALK WITH THE
AUTHOR ABOUT THE BUT OTHERWISE
WE WE DO APPRECIATE THE
NARROWING TO JUST THOSE SERVICES
AN ADDITIONAL -- DECREASE IN
TIME SO -- WITH THAT I THINK
WE'LL JUST CONTINUE WORKS OFFICE
AND GO FROM THERE.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
XENON QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASK THAT YOU JUST FOCUS
THEM ON THE AMENDMENTS AS WE
HEARD ABILITY FOR A SAYING NINE
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION ON THE
BILL -- SO THE MOTION WOULD BE
TO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- SECRETARY
PLEASE.
THE FOR BEFORE I SAY THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING MEN
MEN'S AND I REALLY APPRECIATE I
KNOW YOU.
MAY AGAIN HEARING THE COMMITTEE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE.
CLASS RIVAL OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THAT'S ACTIVE THESE CALL
THE ROLL.
PAN NIGHT CAN I ASK STONE DORADO.
DRAWS -- AYE GROVE HER TADO.
ALTHOUGH I LEYVA BY LIVE I'D
MITCHELL MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
THE BILL CURLY AS FIVE VOTES
WILL PUT ON CALL BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER TO GET IT OUT.
THANK YOU THINK.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT -- LET'S
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TO US ON
THEIR AGUIAR-CURRY I SEE YOU IN
THE AUDIENCE WELCOME.
YEAH AND THEN WILL FLORA PLANTS.
YEAH TWELVE THE RESULT GOING
RECESS WHEN BUDGET HAPPENS WILL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT EVERYTHING.
IN [inaudible]
OKAY WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS FIRST EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
EXPLICITLY PROHIBIT FAULTS
HEALTH CLAIMS.
AB TWO TWO IT CLARIFIES THAT A
FOOD BEVERAGE COSMETIC THEY
CONTAIN CVD DERIVE FROM
INDUSTRIAL HIM.
IS NOT ADULTERATED.
THIS BILL PROHIBITS RESTRICTIONS
ON THE PRODUCTS BASED SOLELY ON
THE FACT THAT THEY CONTAIN CVD
FROM HIM.
ALL OTHER EXISTING FOOD SAFETY
LAWS LAWS WOULD APPLY.
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
FEDERAL FARM BILL REMOVED HIM
FROM ALL FTA SCHEDULES AND WE
CLASS OF IT RE CLASSIFIED HIM AS
AN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT.
THIS OPENS THE DOOR FOR
CALIFORNIA FARMERS TO CULTIVATE
HIM AND IT'S PRESENTED CONSUMERS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
CB DE.
THAT WILL NOT RESULT IN A HIGH.
THIS IS BECAUSE BY DEFINITION
INDUSTRIAL HIM ONLY CONTAINS
THREE TENTHS OF A PERCENT THC OR
LESS WHICH IS THE CYCLE ACTIVE
COMPONENT [inaudible]
PRODUCTS.
THE MANUFACTURE SALE AND SUSAN
THE MANUFACTURE AND SALE OF HIM
SEE MEDIAN CALIFORNIA IS RAPIDLY
EXPANDING BUSINESS WITH OVER A
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
WE CAN ALREADY BUY THESE
PRODUCTS TODAY AT LOCAL GYMS
COFFEE SHOPS WELLNESS STORES AND
EVEN NOW IS CVS.
SHOULD THE STATE NOT CHOOSE TO
CLARIFY THE HEAD THAT HIM CVD
PRODUCTS ARE LEGAL.
THESE JOBS IN BUSINESS IN THIS
BUSINESS WOULD BE LOST.
AND CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS THAT
CURRENTLY PURCHASE TEMP CVD
PRODUCTS WILL FACE A NEW BARRIER
IN OBTAINING WHAT THEY NEED.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE WITH
UNCERTAINTY AS TO WHETHER HAVE
DERIVE CVD MAY BE LAWFULLY SOLD
IN PERSON CALIFORNIA.
I ASKED FOR I VOTE FOR IT AB TWO
TWO EIGHT THAT OUR CITIZENS CAN
LAWFULLY ACCESS THIS NOT
INTOXICATING ALTERNATIVE PRODUCT.
I HAVE WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT WE
HAVE.
THAT TOTAL DISMAY IS SIX MINUTES
MONTH ALL THE WITNESSES OKAY FAR
LESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR RED BEAR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIM COUNSEL
HERE TODAY OF SUPPORT OF AB.
TWO TWO EIGHT AND CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN A LEADER IN WITHIN HIM
INDUSTRY BY.
A LONG SHOT AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THE WELL TO NOW
CULTIVATE AND PRODUCE PRODUCTS
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH AN UNBIASED -- IN OPEN
ACCESS TYPE OF OF APPROACH I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT AND
EMPHASIZE WHAT THE THE AUTHOR
HAS STATED THAT THESE WILL BE
SUBJECT TO ALL THE RETAIL FOOD
TESTING REQUIREMENTS OF ANY
OTHER FOOD PRODUCT.
IN ADDITION TO THAT HEMP AS A
CROP WILL BE SUBJECT TO THE FOOD
SAFETY MODERNIZATION ACT
REGULATIONS THAT ALSO EXIST FOR
PRODUCE THE SOLD IN THE STATE SO.
THE REGULATIONS EXHAUSTIVE AND
EXPANSIVE SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE
THANK YOU FOR AND OF SUPPORT AB.
TWO TWO EIGHT BILL NUMBER OWSKI
REPRESENTING US HAVE HIM BROWN
TABLE.
OF I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
STAFF ON THE ANALYSIS OF IT
SUMMARIZES THE ISSUES EXTREMELY
WELL -- AND POINT OUT THE
ANALYSIS DOES INCLUDE THIS
LANGUAGE.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT FOOD
DRINKS AND COSMETICS THAT
CONTAIN HEMP DERIVE CVD ARE
LEGAL FOR SALE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT WE
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE TO STAND UNITED
AND STRONG SUPPORT -- WITH THE
THEY HAVE COMMUNITY ON THIS BILL
AND THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP -- FROM AND AND
CANNABIS INDUSTRY PERSPECTIVE WE
ARE VERY PLEASED WITH.
IN THE BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
INDUSTRY TO A CANNABIS INDUSTRY
TO MANUFACTURE AND SELL THESE
PRODUCTS -- THIS IS A CO A
PORTENT COMPONENT OF THE
INDUSTRY CAP CITIES BEEN ENGAGED
IN THE SALE -- AND MANUFACTURE
OF HIM FOR SOME TIME SO -- WE
APPRECIATE THIS CLARITY -- IT
WILL HELP US AS WE CONTINUE --
TO ADJUST TO OUR NEW ECONOMIC
REALITY IS A REGULATED ENTITY
AND THINK AGAIN THANK THE AUTHOR
NURTURE SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT THAT'S MEASURE MEMBERS
TO THE RAND MARTIN ON THE HAVE A
COOLEY THE ONE OF THE LARGEST
CANNABIS OPERATORS IN THE STATE
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK.
AFTERNOON MISTER TERRY MEMBERS
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF NOR
CAL CANNABIS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT WITH PRECISION
ADVOCACY GROUP ON BEHALF OF
BLOOM FARMS CAN A CRAFT NEW
TROPIC REGULATED SOLUTIONS GROUP
AND TERROR ATTACK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER ROW ON THE OFFICER
TERRA HOLDINGS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
WALGREENS CVS CONSULTING
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE GRANGE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
OLDEST AGRICULTURE ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT'S
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELL QUITE AND ASIO.
ACCESS TRONG A SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANKS THANK YOU.
CARA CROSS THE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS MANY FACTORS
ASSOCIATION WITH SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
RICHARD HERMAN BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF IMPERIAL THE CITY OF
OAKLAND THE CITY OF AND REVEALED
CURA AND MARKS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU -- EXTENSION OF A HALF
OF A HUMP IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THINKING.
JUSTIN BATON ONE A ONE HAMPSHIRE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THANKS
THANK YOU.
SEEN OTHER PEOPLE OF MICROPHONE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON OPPOSITION QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT'S BEEN
MOVED -- BY CENTER GROVE.
RIGHT SO FAST [inaudible]
OPPOSITION OKAY.
YEAH I DO I DO THERE YOU CAN
COME UP TO THE TABLE OF THE
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF FIRST
HELLO MY NAME IS SORRY MY VOICE.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE SKIRBALL
Là AND I'M A FORMER PROFESSOR
AT UC BERKELEY A TOXICOLOGIST
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH SCIENTIST.
AND MY CONCERN IS THAT HEMP IS A
SUPER BIO ACCUMULATOR.
OF TOXIC HEAVY METALS AND
PESTICIDES.
AND WE ARE.
I AM VERY CONCERNED FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFETY IN THE WAY THE
WORDING AND THE BILL IS RIGHT
NOW WHERE IT'S VERY VAGUE ABOUT
WHAT KIND OF TESTING WILL
ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE DONE -- I
THINK THAT IT SHOULD AT LEAST
FOLLOW PROP SIXTY FIVE
THRESHOLDS. FOR TESTING -- IN
CAT FOR CANNABIS WE HAVE EVEN
STRICTER TESTING AND I FEEL THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO PAY ATTENTION.
TO THE ULTIMATE.
NEEDS AND HEALTH OF OUR CITIZENS
OF THIS COUNTRY.
AND OTHER STATES IN ALLOWING
PRODUCTS TO GET ON THE MARKET.
THAT ARE HEAVILY TAINTED FOR
THAT HAVE VERY HIGH LEVELS BUT
FELL PASSED SOME KIND OF A VERY
SOFT.
A THRESHOLD FOR OUR WHATEVER TO
TESTING IS IN PLACE SO I REALLY
URGE ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE.
RECONSIDER.
MAKING THE WORDING MORE SPECIFIC.
FOR EXACTLY HOW YOU KNOW NOT
JUST SAYING -- IT'S GOING TO BE
LIKE ALL THE OTHER FOODS.
NOW IT'S NOT LIKE FOODS PEOPLE
ARE TAKING THIS IS MADISON.
ALL THAT ARE TAKEN AS HOT
THEY'RE SUSCEPTIBLE POPULATIONS
AS IT IS.
SO WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE SICK
WE IT WILL BE GIVEN THIS
MEDICINE.
BECAUSE THEY WILL USE IT OF
AND WE'RE NOT PROTECTING THEM IF
WE ALLOW.
THE BILL TO GO THROUGH AS IT IS
CURRENTLY WORDED.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME THANK
YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
THESE COME AT THE NECK FRAGRANT
YET YOU CAN JUST GIVE HERE.
HI -- THANK YOU ALL FOR
LISTENING HERE TODAY -- MY
NAME'S NICOLE AND A LICENSE
CANNABIS MANUFACTURER I ALSO
OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR A FEW
REASONS -- FIRST THIS BILL DOES
NOT PROPERLY DEFINED INDUSTRIAL
HEMP.
AS WE SAW WITH THE RECENT LETTER
FROM THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS.
PEOPLE ARE CULTIVATING HIGH CBD
CANNABIS THE CALLING AT HOME WE
NEED STRICTER GUIDELINES AND
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL THAT
ACTUALLY SPECIFIES WHAT IS
INDUSTRIAL HAMPERS IS WHAT IS%
CANNABIS BEING SOLD ON THE OPEN
MARKET -- THE SECOND KIND OF
PIGGYBACKING ON THAT IS THAT.
BY ALLOWING HEMP INTO THE
CANNABIS MANUFACTURE CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN THE STATE IS LOSING
OUT ON CULTIVATION TAX FROM.
CULTIVATORS IN CALIFORNIA HER
LICENSE FARMERS IN A GROWING
HIGH CVD PRODUCTS WE NEED TO
SUPPORT AND PROTECT THE VERY
FRAGILE.
MANUFACTURED CANNABIS SUPPLY
CHAIN -- LEAVE THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE IN THE FARM BILL WHICH
THE VAGUENESS ALSO IT'S PASSED
ON TO THIS BILL ABOUT ALLOWABLE
THC BEING POINT THREE DELTA NINE
THRESHOLD -- THAT LANGUAGE
SHOULD INCLUDE DELTA EIGHT IT
SHOULD ALSO INCLUDE TEACH CA
WHICH IS EASILY CONVERTIBLE WITH
HEAT AND A PRODUCTS SITTING ON A
SHELF OVER TIME -- BY NOT
REGULATING THOSE YOU'RE CREATING
GROSS LOOPHOLES THAT WERE WILL
ALLOW CYCLE ACTIVE PRODUCTS TO
BE SOLD ON THE OPEN MARKET AS WE
ARE ALREADY SEEING AS LICENSE
MANUFACTURERS -- SO.
IN CONCLUSION THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IS IN A VERY FRAGILE
PLACE RIGHT NOW -- I URGE YOU
ALL TO GIVE US A FAIR SHOT AT
COMPETING IN THE HIGH CBT
MEDICINAL CANNABIS MARKET AND
LICENSE DISPENSARIES.
CURRENTLY THIS BILL UNDERMINES
THAT BY ALLOWING HAVE BEEN TO
THE SUPPLY CHAIN THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION OKAY SAYING NINE AND
THERE'S A MOTION YES -- CENTER
GROWTH.
YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS NOW THAT
OPPOSITION HAS SPOKEN.
IN YOUR STATEMENT IN THE WAY I
READ BILL THERE'S IT'S NOT
PSYCHO ACTIVE PRODUCTS IN THIS --
IN IT PASSES ALL FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT GETS PENINSULA GET BRADBURY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL
LET ME JUST BE CLEAR IN
CALIFORNIA IF IT EXCEEDS A POINT
3% THC THRESHOLD.
IS NOT CONSIDERED HIM.
DESTROYED BEFORE IT IS HARVESTED
IS IN FACT IT IS TESTED IN THE
FIELD AND AND HAS TO PASS THAT
TEST THIRTY DAYS BEFORE IT'S
HARVESTED WITH THE PLAN OUT A
GOOD ABOUT AND MUST BE.
AGAIN AS I SAID DESTROYED --
WITH REGARD TO THE FDA QUESTION
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT ANYBODY WHO'S GOING TO
MANUFACTURE AND HIM PRODUCT --
IN THE STATE HAS TO REGISTER
UNDER THE HEALTH AND THE IF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE AS A
MANUFACTURER AND FOLLOW THE
CURRENT GOOD MANUFACTURING
PRACTICES WHICH IS THE SAME
PROCESSES THAT EVERY FOOD
PRODUCT IN THE STATE.
HAS TO GO THROUGH THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- APPRECIATE-- THEIR
RESPONSE -- THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED -- BY CENTER GROVE -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SO I GUESS
I'LL SEE THAT BILL THERE.
AGAIN -- IS -- SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HAND BY PAN AYE STONE DORADO
GROVE.
GROVE I HEARD TOTO LEYVA
MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
OKAY WELL MOST OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE UP AND BUDGET -- BUT THE BUT
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
THANKS MUCH I WILL ALSO BE
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
IT'S RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM
GRAY.
I DO THAT NOW YES YOU MAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO THAT'S
AYE NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
AGAIN THANK YOU -- CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
AB EIGHT FORTY EIGHT MANDATES
THAT MEDICARE ALL PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE.
MONITORS WHEN MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FOR THE MANAGEMENT AND
TREATMENT OF DIABETES.
CALIFORNIA SUFFERS FROM EXTREME
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES FOR
DIABETICSDIABETIC POPULATION
AND THIS DISPARITY IS
PARTICULARLY ACUTE FOR
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIANS.
THIRD BY MEDI CAL WHO'S
CURRENTLY UNDER GO UP TO TEN
TIMES AS MANY DIABETES RELATED
AMPUTATIONS AS THEIR NON
MEDICARE ALL COUNTERPART PARTS.
MORE THAN TWO POINT THREE
CALIFORNIA ADULTS HAVE DIABETES
WITH 40% 43% OF THIS POPULATION
RECEIVE RECEIVING HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE THROUGH MEDICO.
MEDI CAL CURRENTLY OFFERS ONLY A
FINGER STICK TEST TO MEASURE
BLOOD GLUCOSE LEVELS.
USING THIS METHOD PATIENTS
MEASURE THEIR BLOOD SUGAR LEVELS
ON AVERAGE THREE TIMES A DAY AND
IT JUST SO DOES THE INSULIN
ACCORDINGLY.
HOWEVER THESE INTERMITTENT
SNAPSHOTS OF BLOOD SUGAR FAILS.
A LEVELS FAILED TO ACCOUNT FOR
THE HIGHLY VARIABLE NATURE BLOOD
SUGAR LEVELS AND OFTEN PROVIDES
A FALSE SENSE OF GLUCOSE
MANAGEMENT.
THIS METHOD ALSO FAILS TO
PROVIDE.
DURING SLEEP WHICH IS ESPECIALLY
TROUBLING AS 50% OF PATIENTS
WILL EXPERIENCE NOCTURNAL
HYPOGLYCEMIA AT LEAST ONCE PER
NIGHT.
IN CONTRAST THE GM'S PROVIDE
READINGS EVERY FIVE MINUTES FOR
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT TIMES
PER DAY.
CREATING A FAR MORE ACCURATE AND
CLINICALLY RELEVANT PICTURE A
BLOOD SUGAR LEVELS ALLOWING
INSULIN DELIVERY TO BE ADJUSTED
ACCORDINGLY.
THE GM'S ALSO ALLOW HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS TO UPLOAD INTO VOTE
VISUALIZE PATIENT DATA TO
MONITOR ANY DIFFICULTIES OUR
PATIENTS EXPERIENCE WITH
MANAGING THEIR GLUCOSE LEVELS.
AND MAKE SOUND MEDICAL DECISIONS
BASED ON FULL DAY INFORMATION.
THE GYMS ARE CLINICALLY APPROVED
TO THE BEST MEANS TO MONITOR
GLUCOSE LEVELS AND AVOID THE
POTENTIALLY CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES A POORLY MONITORED
BLOOD SUGAR LEVELS.
SUCH AS HYPERGLYCEMIA
AMPUTATIONS AND BLINDNESS.
AB EIGHT FORTY EIGHT SIMPLY
REQUIRES MEDI CAL TO PROVIDE THE
SAME COVERAGE FOR CONTINUES
BECAUSE CLOSE MONITORS.
AS MEDICARE COVERED CALIFORNIA
THE MEDICAID PROGRAM -- OF MORE
THAN THIRTY OTHER STATES 90% OF
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
PROGRAM.
AB EIGHT FORTY EIGHT IS
SUPPORTED BY THE AMERICAN
DIABETES.
OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AMONG
OTHERS THERE'S BEEN NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY US
REAR I WON'T.
THANK YOU WITH THIS IS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SHARE
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION
AND THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION AS LEADING THE
COALITION.
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT OUR COALITION INCLUDES THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF CLINICAL
ENDOCRINOLOGIST.
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
DIABETES EDUCATORS THE DIABETES
PATIENT ADVOCACY COALITION AND
MANY MORE ARE COALITION SUPPORTS
THE COVERAGE OF CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS WHEN PRESCRIBED
BY A PHYSICIAN AS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY.
ARC OUR COALITION SUPPORTS THE
COVERAGE OF CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORS BECAUSE THE CGM.
ALERT THE WEARER WHEN THEIR
BLOOD CREEK GLUCOSE LEVELS GO
DANGEROUSLY HIGH OR DANGEROUSLY
LOW IN A WAY THAT TRADITIONAL
FINGER STICK MEASUREMENT CAN ON
TRADITIONAL FINGER STICK
MEASUREMENT ONLY SHOWS A
SNAPSHOT OF BLOOD GLUCOSE LEVELS
AT THE MOMENT.
BUT DOES NOT WARN OF RAPIDLY
RISING OR FALLING LEVELS WHICH
IS NECESSARY FOR THE PATIENT TO
MAKE INFORMED AFFECTIVE
DECISIONS AND MAN [inaudible]
OWN DISEASE.
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES USE INSULIN
EXPERIENCE DISPROPORTIONATELY
HIGH RATES OF EMERGENCY ROOM USE
INSTANCES OF HOSPITALIZATION AND
MORTALITY.
ACCORDING TO A TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES REPORT SPENDING
AND THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM
ASSOCIATED WITH ADULTS AND ADULT
INDIVIDUALS TREATED FOR DIABETES.
TOTALED THREE POINT SIX BILLION
WHICH IS APPROXIMATELY 14% OF
TOTAL SPENDING FOR NON DUAL
ELIGIBLES.
IN THE FEE FOR SERVICE PROGRAM
ALLOWING THE MOST COSTLY 5% OF
THOSE TREATED FOR DIABETES
GENERATED ROUGHLY 36% OF ALL
DIABETES SPENDING WELL THE MOST
COSTLY TIME PERCENT GENERATED
OVER 50% OF TOTAL DIABETES
SPENDING.
THESE HIGH RISK PATIENTS WOULD
BENEFIT THE MOST FROM CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE MONITORS.
THE GM CAN IMPROVE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DIABETES AND ALSO REDUCE COSTS
TO THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM BY
REDUCING THE SEVERE HYPOGLYCEMIC
EVENTS.
THAT LEAD TO EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS.
FIJIANS ARE CURRENTLY WIDELY
COVERED IN CALIFORNIA BY PRIVATE
PAYERS AS WELL AS PUBLIC PAYER
SUCH AS MEDICARE AND THE CCS
PROGRAM.
MEANS HE OUT WIRE AB EIGHT FOUR
EIGHT SIX TO CHANGE THAT SO THAT
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM.
CAN HAVE ACCESS TO THE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY DOES DEVICE AS
PRESCRIBED BY THEIR PHYSICIAN IS
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT AB
FOUR EIGHT FOUR EIGHT AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR IPHONE.
OKAY THANK YOU THE SHOW
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BACK MY
JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF OF
ADMITTED BY A COMMON SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
IT ALL REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATIE LATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT SAM STAR ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MR CIRCUS TAPIO MY BOARD MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA JDRF AND HERE
TODAY AS A PARENT OF YOUR MAIL
TYPE ONE DIABETES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
CAN FLORA ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISSY JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY FOR NUTRITION
AND DIETETICS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
RESIDENTS ARE PERHAPS THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYN STITCHES NINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
THE NINE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
GROVE -- WHICH AT THE CERTAINLY
AGREE WITH THAT I THINK THAT
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THIS --
VERY IMPORTANT LIFESAVING AT
TECHNOLOGY SO WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES I WOULD AND IT'S JUST
KIND OF IRONIC THAT I WAS ASKED
TO DO THIS A BILL TODAY.
MY BROTHER AND I HAD FINALLY GOT
TO SEE GM.
IT HAS CHANGED HIS LIFE HE'S A
PRODUCTIVE YOUNG MAN WHO WORKS --
REALLY HARD PROVIDES FOR FAMILY
AND HAVING THIS ON HIM
CONTINUOUSLY HAS CHANGED HIS
LIFE FOR THE BETTER SO.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY
THANK YOU SEPARATE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AT THE MOTION IS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS PAN HI CAN
I STONE DORADO GROVE.
GROVE I HER TADO LEYVA MITCHELL
MONNING RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS TO VOTE SO REAL BUT
THE BILL A CALL HAS AGAIN MISTER
MEMBERS ARE OFTEN BUDGET RIGHT
NOW.
THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH HEY
SUMMER CERVANTES GEN X..
ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE AB SEVEN NINETY EIGHT THE
TERMINAL HOUSES WELCOME TO YOU
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
IN THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED ON PAGE
FOR THE ANALYSIS.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL.
WE CELEBRATE THE BIRTH OF
CHILDREN BUT THE WELL BEING OF
THE MOTHER WHO GIVES BIRTH OFTEN
GETS FORGOTTEN MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS ARE THE MOST
COMMON COMPLICATIONS.
OF THE PRE AND POST PARTUM
STAGES AND THE STIGMA ASSOCIATED
WITH MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
PROCESS WOMEN WHO EXPERIENCE
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
MAY NOT ASK FOR HELP.
AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN SUCH AS A
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION OR
POVERTY CAN CONTRIBUTE TO POOR
DETECTION AND TREATMENT RATES.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH ONE IN FIVE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN WHO RECENTLY
GAVE BIRTH EXPERIENCE SYMPTOMS
OF DEPRESSION DURING OR AFTER
PREGNANCY THIS MEANS THAT
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE ISSUES.
WITH MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
EVERY YEAR. ONE MAJOR OBSTACLE
TO ADDRESSING THIS CRISIS IS THE
LACK OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS.
AB SEVEN NINE EIGHT WILL CREATE
A PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDES
PSYCHIATRY TELE CONSULTATION AND
OR VIRTUAL MENTORING SERVICES TO
HELP ADDRESS MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH.
THIS PILOT PROGRAM OPERATE IN
SEVERAL COUNTIES INCLUDING
RIVERSIDE TO INCREASE THE
CAPACITY OF YOURS FURNISHING
SERVICES TO POST PARTUM WOMEN.
UP TO ONE YEAR AFTER DELIVERY.
THIS BILL WILL HELP.
MAKE IMPORTANT PROGRESS TOWARD
ENSURING THAT WOMEN WITH
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
RECEIVE THE TREATMENT.
THAT THEY ABSOLUTELY NEED AND
DESERVE.
OUR POST PARTUM SUPPORT DURING
THIS CRITICAL TRANSITION SETS
THE STAGE FOR A WOMAN'S WELL
BEING FOR MANY YEARS TO COME WE
MUST NOT ALLOW ANY WOMAN AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO SUFFER IN
SILENCE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I BO
ON THIS BILL TODAY WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AS HE THIS
WORKS HI.
HI I'M EVEN SHORTS -- I HAD I
HAD POSTPARTUM PSYCHOSIS -- WHEN
MY SON WAS TEN DAYS OLD I WAS
COMMITTED TO A MENTAL HOSPITAL?
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE.
I MEAN IT WAS.
MY OF I. TAKING CARE OF MY
FATHER WHO HAD HAD A STROKE FOR
THREE AND DID EVERYTHING FOR HIM.
HE'LL SAY THIS THING WAS WORSE --
IN THE END IT WAS MEDICATION AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
SAVE MY LIFE AND SAY MY
RELATIONSHIP WITH MY FAT -- I
DON'T REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED
THAT MONTH OR THE YEAR AFTER
I'LL HAVE HUGE A AGO.
I DON'T REMEMBER EVERYTHING MY
HUSBAND HAS TO TELL ME IT WAS
NOT GOOD MY SON IS PERFECTLY
HEALTHY FOUR YEAR OLD KID.
YOU KNOW I BUT THAT'S BECAUSE I
GOT THE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT.
I DIDN'T GET A DIVORCE MOST OF
THE PEOPLE DO.
I DIDN'T I DIDN'TEND UP ON THE
STREET AND I DIDN'T AS MY ROUTE
THE PEOPLE I MET IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS BUT I DIDN'T END UP ON
METHAMPHETAMINES OR HEROIN.
I MEAN IT SOUNDS CRAZY BUT
THAT'S WHAT THESE PEOPLE DEBT.
IT'S VERY COMMON.
I HAD HEALTH CARE THE FACT IT IT
THESE WOMEN DON'T IS ABSOLUTELY
TERRIFYING.
THEY NEED IT IT JUST IT'S THE
BASICS OF EVERYTHING ELSE
[inaudible]
THE NUTS.
YEAH.
I DIDN'T LOSE MY MIND BECAUSE OF
THAT [inaudible]
NOTHING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OFFICIALS MANY OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT FOR MY AND HER ON BEHALF
OF THE MARCH OF DIMES IN SUPPORT.
BRENT SPENCER PAP THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OWES YOU ENDS
DISTRICT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I KNOW ONLY.
OKAY ASTOR GROVES MOVE THE BILL --
I THE I UNDERSTAND THAT --
SINNERS RATHER THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
CERTAINLY THE RIGHT EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND APPRECIATE
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AS WELL -- I
UNDERSTAND THAT ACCORDING YOUR
BILL YOU GUYS SEEK PRIVATE
FUNDING DO YOU AT THE F. ARE YOU
YOU'RE JUST HOPING THAT
SOMETHING WILL SHOW UP AT OUR
DATA IS THERE SOMETHING LINED UP.
AT THIS POINT CURRENTLY THERE'S
NOTHING LINED UP AT THIS POINT
BUT WE HOPE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION -- IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT OKAY SO I JUST
MADE NOTE THAT IN THE BILLS SO
YOU ARE THAT YOU'RE SEEKING
PRIVATE FUNDING SO.
OKAY AB AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND AND TAKING YES THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER GROVE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE -- ON THIS MATTER
THAT AFFECTS SO MANY FAMILIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU BASICALLY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL -- THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AND BY PAN AYE STONE DORADO
GROVE GROVE I HEARD TACO LEYVA
MITCHELL MONNING.
THE BILL HAS TO VOTE SAYS I
MENTIONED OF MANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE AND BUDGET
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW SO THEY'LL
BE COMING DOWN LATER ON THE BILL
CALLS THANK YOU THANKS MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RACE THAT THEY
ARE SO YOU BACK THERE ARE EIGHT
WELCOME SO IT'S ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB
.
EIGHT TWENTY SIX THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
[inaudible]
I FOR FOSTER YOUTH WERE PLACED
OUT OF COUNTY IN SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAMS
KNOWN AS STR TEEPEES.
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WHICH CHARGE I CHAIR
HAS HELD TO HEARINGS IN THE PAST
YEAR REGARDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
ISSUE THE RECEIVED PARTICULAR
ATTENTION WAS PRESUMPTIVE
TRANSFER.
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER IS THE
PROCESS BY WHICH THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROVIDING
SPECIAL TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO FOSTER YOUTH WERE
PLACED OUT OF COUNTY.
UP OUT [inaudible]
OUR TRANSIT.
REPLACED OUT OF COUNTY IS
TRANSFERRED FROM THE COUNTY OF
ORIGINAL JURISDICTION TO THE
COUNTY IN WHICH THE YOUTH
DISPLACED KNOWN AS COUNTY OF
RESIDENCE.
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER WAS ADOPTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WELL
SIGNIFICANT REFORMS WERE BEING
MADE TO THE STATE'S CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. ONE OF THESE
REFORMS WAS TO END THE STATE'S
RELIANCE ON GROUP HOMES AS
ACCEPTABLE LONG TERM PLACEMENTS
FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
INSTEAD TO GROUP HOMES ARE BEING
REPLACED BY STR TEEPEES WHICH
PROVIDE SHORT TERM MENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
FOSTER YOUTH WHO NEED A
SPECIALIZED INTENSIVE SERVICES.
PRIOR TO MOVING TO A FAMILY HOME.
FOR FOSTER YOUTH WERE PLACED OUT
OF COUNTY IN AN S. T. R. T. P.
IT OFTEN DOES NOT MAKE SENSE TO
TRANSFER THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
FROM THEIR HOME COUNTY
ESPECIALLY WHEN AN S. T. R. T.
P. BY ITS VERY NATURE IS MEANT
TO BE SHORT TERM.
ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
FOR A FOSTER YOUTH PLACE IN OUT
OF COUNTY CONGREGATE CARE
SETTINGS.
AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX ACCOMPLICES
SEVERAL THINGS.
IT ENSURES ADEQUATE AND TIMELY
PROVISION OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO FOSTER YOUTH BY
MAKING PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER THE
EXCEPTION.
RATHER THAN THE RULE FOR YOUTH
PLACED AN S. T. R. T. PIECE.
IT ALSO ESTABLISHES MORE
TRANSPARENT IN UNIFORM PROCESSES
AND REQUIRES DATA ON IMPACTED
YOUTH TO BE COLLECTED AND
REPORTED.
I WANT TO TAKE THE SAP
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK COULD THE
OPPOSITION FOR ENGAGING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THE ISSUES.
THEY'VE RAISED.
I THINK WE SHARE THE SAME GOAL
OF PROVIDING QUALITY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO FOSTER YOUTH
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION MOVING
FORWARD IN FIGURING OUT HOW
COULDHOW WE CAN ACHIEVE THE
SHARED GOAL.
THE PURPOSE OF THE CHILD WELFARE%
SYSTEM IS TO PROVIDE OUR STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE YOUTH WITH
SERVICES SUPPORT.
AND THE CARE THAT THEY NEED TO
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD AND LEAD
SUCCESSFUL FILLING LIVES AB
EIGHT TWENTY SIX FURTHERS THIS
PURPOSE.
HERE TO TESTIFY WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE KATHY
SANDERLING WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
FOR A MAKE DALE **** TING.
WITH.
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND PHOEBE.
BELL ON BEHALF OF NEVER NEVADA
COUNTY.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IN THIS IS A SUPPORT
AGAIN IF YOU CAN KEEP SIX
MINUTES OR LESS ALL COLLECTIVELY
THAT BE GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ENVIRONMENT THEY TING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT A
CALIFORNIA.
COUNTIES WHEN TWELVE NINETY NINE
WAS -- BE NEGOTIATED IN --
TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE COUNTY CROWD
AS IT WERE WORKED VERY HARD TO
TRY TO MEET THE GOALS OF THE
BILL'S SPONSORS.
AND IT TOOK ALMOST TWO YEARS BUT
WE ARRIVED AT AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE WHICH WE THOUGHT WAS A
REALLY GOOD PRODUCT.
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT HOW
IT WOULD WORK FOR A COUPLE YEARS
IN NOW AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED.
AND WE'RE FINDING THAT THERE'S
SOME TECHNICAL THINGS THAT
AREN'T QUITE WORKING AS WELL --
I'LL BE SPEAKING VERY SHORTLY AS
WELL MISS CENTRALLY MCDONNELL
BUT REALLY OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR FROM NEVADA COUNTY MISS
HALL HAS THE THE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE OF WHY WE NEED A
TECHNICAL FIX HERE -- WE THINK
THAT AB TWENTY SIX BUT PROVIDES
THIS CLARITY TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THIS TO YOUR GP PLAISANCE.
BY UTILIZING THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS WITH THE CHILD AND
FAMILY TEAMS IT ALSO REQUIRES
BETTER COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
PLACING COUNTY AND THAT COUNTY
OF RESIDENCE.
AND THEN -- MORE COLLECTION.
WE ONLY AND I THINK EVERYBODY --
EVEN OPPOSITION THIS BILL REALLY
SUPPORT STRONGLY -- AND THEN OF
COURSE -- WE WE JUST WANTTO
MAKE IT WORK BETTER AND WE THINK
THAT AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX IS A
GREAT VEHICLE FOR THAT --
BECAUSE OF THAT ALL THE COUNTY
OR TO GET ORGANIZATIONS THAT
INCLUDES OF COURSE THE WTA SEE
SACK -- AND OTHERS WHO WILL
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AS WELL WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE CURRENT
VERSION OF AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY I'M GONNA PASADENA
CENTRALLY MCDONNELL.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CAN CENTER L<c.cyan>G WITH</c>
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
ON AS YOU HEARD THIS BILL REALLY
BUILDS ON THESE CONVERSATIONS
THAT HAPPENED DURING THE
HEARINGS THEY WERE REALLY ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS AND I THINK.
BROUGHT TO LIGHT AREAS WHERE THE
BILL'S WORKING REALLY WELL IN
AREAS WHERE CHANGES ARE NEEDED
TO MAKE IT WORK BETTER.
IN PARTICULAR THE AREAS OF THOSE
TRANSFERS WHEN A CHILD IS PLACED
INTO GROUP HOMER S. HERE T. P.
TYPE OF FACILITY THE NEW VERSION
OF THE GROUP COMES UNDER THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE OF FORM.
AND SO THE BILL FOCUS OF A LOT
IN PA ON THOSE CHILDREN BECAUSE
THINGS SEEM TO BE WORKING WELL
FOR THE CHILDREN HER WITH A
RELATIVE A GRANDPARENT OR A
TRADITIONAL HOME.
WE THINK THAT -- ASPECTS OF THE
UNIFORMITY OF FORMS AND WORK
TOWARD MORE UNIFORM --
CONTRACTING -- FOR COUNTIES TO
BE ABLE TO DRAW UPON WILL HELP.
REYES OF COMMUNICATION AND WITH
THE SPEED IN WHICH THINGS ARE
TRANSFERRED SO THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE CHILD IS COMING
AND THEY'RE TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY AND HERE'S WHAT
THEY NEED AND SO WE THINK THAT
THOSE CHANGES IN THE BILL ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT AS WELL.
AND ON IN ADDITION CHANGING THE
STRUCTURE OF HOW WE PRESUME
WHETHER OR NOT TO TRANSFER THAT
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE CASE OF A
CHILD IS IN A GROUP HOME.
DOES I THINK DO A BETTER JOB NOW
OF REFLECTING WHAT WE'VE SEEN
SINCE THE CONTINUE OF CARE
REFORM WAS ENACTED WHICH IS --
WE'VE LOST A LOT OF GROUP HELP
GROUP CARE FACILITIES AND THAT
WAS EXPECTED ON THE LOWER LEVEL
HOMES WERE WERE WORKING TO FIND.
PLACES FOR THE CHILDREN OF
FAMILIES AND SO THEY'RE BETTER
ABLE TO BE SERVED IN THOSE AND
SO YOU SEE SOME CHANGES RELATED
TO THAT -- AND SO -- WE JUST
OVERALL REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE AUTHOR AND
STAFF ON IN THE FIRST HOUSE AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL IN THE
CURRENT FORM IN OF COURSE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
CONVERSATIONS.
I'D LIKE TO YOU KNOW THE OLD THE
REST OF OUR TIME TO TO MESS HALL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PHOEBE BELL
DIRECTOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH FOR
NEVADA COUNTY AND I'M HERE TO
SHARE THIS PART I COUNTY HAS FOR
A. B. EIGHT TWENTY SIX AS
WRITTEN AND IMPORTANT CHANGES IT
MAKES A. B.. TWELVE NINETY NINE
SPECIFICALLY WE BELIEVE THIS
TEAR TO BE SHOULD BE EXEMPTED
FROM THE PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER
PROCESS WITH THE EXCEPTIONS.
IN THIS BILL.
NEVADA COUNTY BELIEVES DEEPLY IN
CONTINUITY OF CARE AND ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR ALL
CHILDREN BUT PARTICULARLY
CHILDREN FACING THE DRAMATIC
EXPERIENCE ABOUT OF HOME
PLACEMENTS IN OUT OF COMMUNITY
PLACEMENTS.
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER WAS CREATED
TO ADDRESS THIS GOAL WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE SUPPORT THAT
DEEPLY.
HOWEVER WHEN A CHILD'S PLACE IN
A RESIDENTIAL SETTING SUCH AS AN
S. T. R. T. P..
TRANSFERRING RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEIR CARE TO A NEW COUNTY DOES
NOT AID IN THE TIMELY ACCESS TO
QUALITY INAPPROPRIATE CARE.
AND JUST AS IMPORTANTLY THAT
PROCESS HAS CREATED SOME
UNINTENDED BUT SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS ON FISCAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITIES AND
SMALL COUNTY SUCH AS NEVADA%
COUNTY WHICH COULD BE
DEVASTATING.
SO WHAT THIS IS LOOK LIKE FOR
NEVADA COUNTY SPECIFICALLY -- IN
OUR COUNTY WE HAVE TWO S. T. R.
TEEPEES WHICH EACH HAVE TWELVE
BEDS -- THAT OUR LICENSING COULD
BE FILLED WITH TRANSFERRED YOUTH.
OVER THE PAST YEAR WE'VE HAD
FORTY FOUR YOUTH TRANSFERRED TO
US AND MORE IN PROCESS AS WE
SPEAK. THIRTY THE COME FROM
TWENTY DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
AND IF BOTH OF OUR AUSTERITY
PEAS WERE FILLED WITH
TRANSFERRED YOUTH FOR THE FOUGHT
THE UPCOMING YEAR THE FISCAL
BURDEN TO US TO BE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
PUT THOSE NUMBERS IN A LITTLE
BIT OF CONTEXT FOR SMALL COUNTY.
WE TYPICALLY HELD A SMALL
CONTRACT WITH ONE OF OUR S. T.
R. TWO PEAS IN CASE IT LOCAL
YOUTH NEED ABOUT LEVEL OF CARE.
MOST YEARS WE THE U. ZERO
DOLLARS THAT SERVICE ON AVERAGE
ABOUT.
TWENTY THOUSAND ABOUT ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE CONTEXT OF THOSE FORTY
FOUR YOU THAT HAVE BEEN
TRANSFERRED TO OUR COMMUNITY IN
THAT SAME TIME PAID WE
TRANSFERRED FIVE YOU THOUGHT OF
IN ABOUT A COUNTY AND TEST THE
R. T. P. SETTINGS.
AND THEN LASTLY SPENDING ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON OUT
OF COUNTY YOUTH -- THE IMPACTS
ARE.
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
ALLOCATION AND ULTIMATELY COULD%
IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE SERVICES THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO DO RIGHT NOW.
THE ONE OTHER THING I WANT TO
TRANSFERRED INTO C. R. T. PEAS
FROM OUR COUNTY OF FIVE REFLECTS
NOT JUST OUR SMALL POPULATION
BASE BUT ALSO OUR DEEP
COMMITMENT.
TO INTENSIVE SERVICES THAT ALLOW
CHILDREN AND YOU TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE HOME SETTING
OUR COMMUNITY SETTING AS OFTEN
AS POSSIBLE.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO JEOPARDIZE
THAT INVESTMENT IN WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS IN HERE INSTEAD A
CONTINUING CARE REFORM
PRINCIPLES.
THE TENSION MAYBE TWELVE NINETY
NINE WAS THE STREAMLINED CARE
FOR CHILDREN THE GOAL THAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AND WE BELIEVE BLANK INCLUSION
INVEST HERE TEEPEES IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE THAT GOAL WE
THINK IT FRAGMENTS CARE FOR
THEIR BY ENDING A CHILD'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR HOME
COMMUNITY IN THEIR HOME SYSTEMS
OF SUPPORT.
AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX IS AN
APPROPRIATE EXTENSION IN THE
SPIRIT OF AB.
TWELVE NINETY NINE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE WAS NOT CREATED TO SIMPLIFY
ADMINISTRATOR FISCAL FUNCTIONS
FIRST YEAR TWO PEAS.
CARE FOR CHILDREN. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE REALLY HOPE THE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITH
THIS IS A SUPPORT.
THE WITNESS SUPPORT BACK BACK
FROM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH --
THE THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AND
WHAT A LINE OUR COMMENTS -- WITH
THEM AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
REVENUE MISTER TURN MEMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON ALLENTOWN ON BEHALF OF
THAT VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MAKE ROOM FOR THE WELCOME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I THINK I HAVE
MY NAME IS DOCTOR LINTHAL I'M A
PRACTICING PSYCHOLOGIST ACTUALLY
HERE IN YOUR DISTRICT.
AND TODAY I'M REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICE WE ARE THE
SPONSOR AND ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE NINETY NINE OUR MEMBERS
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL ACTUALLY TO AN EXTENT QUITE
HONESTLY IT SURPRISED US.
AND EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
COMPONENTS THAT WE FULLY SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THE OPPOSITION --
FROM OUR MEN.
NOT ALL OF US TO SUPPORT IT OR
EVEN SUPPORT IF AMEND.
WE SPONSOR THIS BILL ARE SORRY
AB -- TWELVE NINETY NINE BACK IN
THE DAY BECAUSE OF THE LONG
STANDING PROBLEM OF CHILDREN
HERE PLACE OUT OF CARE RECEIVING
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO WHICH THEY ARE ENTITLED.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DATA
THAT AND YOUR QUARTER THE REPORT
RISK CORDON AROUND PORT IN YOUR
ANALYSIS.
OF CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL DID YOU
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT PLACEMENTS
WHERE THE CHILDREN WERE PLACED
AND THE LOWEST RATE OF RECEIVING
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
WHEN THEY'RE OUT OF COUNTY.
IS ACTUALLY WHEN THEY'RE PLACED
IN GROUP CARE.
SO KIDS THAT WERE PLACED IN
GROUP CARE OUT OF COUNTY WORD
AND NINETEEN POINT 2% RATE OF
GETTING EVEN A SINGLE SERVICE.
INDIVIDUALS IN COMPARISON WHO
ARE PLACED IN FOSTER CARE WHICH
BY ARGUMENT BUT HAVE LESS OF A
NEED FOR SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
WAS AT THIRTY SEVEN POINT 2% --
SO THAT REALLY SHOWS THAT THIS
BILL THE BIGGEST NEED FOR THIS
BILL ARE CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITIES.
I'M AWARE.
OF I DO IT LET ME BACK UP AND
SAY THAT WE ALSO PRESENT
REPRESENT AS CHARITY PIECE SO WE
PERCENT PROVIDER REPRESENT
PROVIDER ASSOCIATIONS.
SO THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE THESE CHILDREN.
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
AND THE WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THIS FIXES THE RUN PROBLEM HAS --
DIRECTOR BELL SAID FROM NEVADA
COUNTY THE PROBLEM THAT SHE IS
EXPERIENCING IS THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGE WE HAD THAT IN THE
ORIGINAL TWELVE NINETY NINE BILL.
IT WAS AMENDED OUT THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND WE DO THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE THE CORRECT FIX.
IT WAS NOT ADDRESSED IN THE
HEARINGS THAT WE HAD ON TWELVE
NINETY NINE ISSUES SO IT WAS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WAS CONSIDERED AS
A POSSIBLE FIX AT THAT TIME.
ABSENT BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE
REASONS WE'RE GLAD WE GET TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAFF -- BUT WE DO AT THIS TIME
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TINA AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION FOR THE
BILL -- SO I I GUESS ARE YOU
WITH THE SAYS THIS QUESTION IN
TERMS OF SO THE OPPOSITION REYES
SEVERAL ISSUES I GUESS ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS I WOULD HAVE I I
PRESUME YOU CAN TELL ME WHAT I
GOT THE POINT THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO MAKE YOURSELF FOR EXAMPLE YOU
HAVE.
IT SO I ENTER CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM OF OKAY
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT.
THE CHILD IS TRANSFERRED TO THE
NEXT YEAR THE P..
CAN I LIKE NEVADA COUNTY RIGHT
AND THEY'RE SORT OF A BURDEN
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS NOW THAT
THERE WAS A PRESUMPTION DAY INTO
PICKING UP EVERYTHING SITE FROM
EVERYONE FROM THE BAY AREA AND
OTHER PLACES RIGHT -- SO THEY
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS SO.
SO IS SO IS IT GOING TO BE THE
REGIONAL COUNTY THAT TO SUPPOSED
TO COVER THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
SO THEY HAVE A RIGHT WE HAVE
MANAGED CARE YEAH WE HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH MANAGED CARE UNDER
MEDICARE AL IT'S THAT OR THAT'S
WHAT THE FOSTER CARE YOUTH ARE
ON SO.
WITH THAT SO WOULD THAT'S A SAN
FRANCISCO I I'M NOT GONNA TAKE I
SHOULD PICK UP SAN FRANCISCO.
SATURDAY SACRAMENTO CENTS ON THE
DOWN THERE THAT ENDED ABOUT A
COUNTY WILL NEVER DO THAT.
I DON'T KNOW BUT ANYWAY SO AND
THEN THEY GET IN THERE AND AS
THE R. P. AND AND WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT WELL THEY MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS IS.
SACRAMENTO HAS THEIR OWN MENTAL
HEALTH YOU KNOW MAN MEDI CAL
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN THAT WITH.
THE HEALTH PROVIDERS IN
SACRAMENTO ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO
PAY NEVADA FOR THIS HOUSE THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO WORK SO THE BEYOND
THE YEAH IN ADDITION TO JUST THE
FOSTER CARE PIECE OF AT THE
MENTAL HEALTH THESE THAT THE
MEDICAL COVERAGE.
SENATOR YOU'VE HIT UPON THE KEY
QUESTION AND WHY WE ALL WERE AT
THE TABLE FOR AB TWELVE NINETY
NINE WHICH WAS. TOO OFTEN I
COUNTY WOULD TRANSFER CHILD WHAT
IT WAS WITH THE KINSHIP
PLACEMENT OR TO A GROUP HOME AT
THE TIME.
AND THE COUNTY IN WHICH ONES
WOULD SAY WELL IT'S NOT OUR KIDS
IT'S IF YOUR KIDS SACRAMENTO YOU
PAY FOR IT AND THAT BACK AND
FORTH.
WOULD MEAN THAT THE CHILD WOULD
RECEIVE THE SERVICES SO TWELVE
MONEY NINE ENDEAVORED TO SAY NO
IF A CHILD IS TRANSFERRED THEIR
TIGHT THEY GET THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
ALSO ALL FOSTER CHILDREN ARE
ENTITLED TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES UNDER A PFD T. SO
THERE'S NO QUESTION YOU KNOW
THAT A CHILD THEY GET ASSESSED.
UNDER MEDICAL NECESSITY WHAT
THEY NEED IS WHAT THEY GET AND
SHOULD GET TO SO IT'S NOT A LIKE --
THE TO KAISER PATIENT OR IT'S A
FOR THAT MATTER MEDICAL MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM WE COVER THOSE
CHILDREN AND SO FOR THE SMALL
CAN IS LIKE ABOUT A REALLY THIS
IS THE COLLISION BETWEEN.
MAYBE CALL NINETY NINE WHICH WE
WORK OUT TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WE
STILL HAVE GROUP HOMES IN THE
LANDSCAPE.
AND NOW WE HAVE THE S. T. R. T.
P. WHICH IS A HIGHER THERAPEUTIC
MODEL.
AND SO THOSE GROUP HOMES THAT
MAYBE DIDN'T HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WERE THE ONES WHERE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
TRANSFERRED HAPPENS TO THOSE
KIDS GOT THE SERVICES THE
AUSTERITY PLEASE.
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES WHETHER
THEY CONTRACT WITH THE COUNTY TO
PROVIDE IT OR THEY PROVIDED IN
HOUSE BUT THE IN THEIR RATE IT'S
COVERED TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES SO WITH SO YEARS THE
TIME TO GET TO THE POINT OF IT
IS A BASICALLY SO THAT UNDER
THIS BILL.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS IS THAT
THAT CHILD TO USE REFER TESTY
RPGS NOT TO DO THAT AND AS PRIDE
GOING TO COME BACK?
THEY SEND IT OVER THEIR EXCESS
CAN THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR PLAN
TO SETTLE DOWN THE BODY COUNTY
YEAH REALLY TO SERVE THAT'S WHAT
THE FACILITY IS I SENT OVER AND
WHEN THEY GET BETTER I BRING
ABOUT.
YEAH THEN IN THE S. T. R. P.
RATE THAT THE A SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND PICK ON MY OWN COUNTY
WOULD HAVE TO PAY WITH AN
INCLUDE BEING CLOSE OF ALL THE
MEDI CAL PIECES THAT WOULD -- SO
LIKE IT I'M JUST TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE'RE LOSE PAYING THE
BILLS SO YOU COULD UNDERSTAND
UNDER THIS BILL YOU'RE SAYING
WHEN THE BY COUNTY SHOULD HAVE
TO PAY THE BILL RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THERE.
IT DEALT THAT DID TO GETTING THE
BASICALLY TAKE YOUR RECEDING BUT
THEY'RE NOT.
WE'RE OVER BURNING THEMSELVES
WHO IS PAYING THE THE HEALTH
MENTAL HEALTH BILLS FOR THIS AND
HOW IS THAT GOING TO BE PAID BY.
WHO'S PAYING AND HOW IT HERE
HOW'S IT GOING TO BE PAID UNDER
THIS BILL UNDER THIS BILL IT
WOULD BE FOR CHILD IT'S GOING TO
BE PLACED IN S. T. R. T. P..
THE CHILD AND FAMILY TEAM WITH
SOME EXCEPTIONS WOULD LOOK AND
SEE IS IT WORTH THE TRANSFER AND
SO INSTEAD OF TRANSFERRING
WITHOUT ASKING QUESTIONS WHICH
IS WHAT TWELVE NINETY NINE IS
IT'S WELL WAIT LET'S ASK
QUESTIONS WILL THEY BE THERE.
SHORT TERM DO THEY HAVE A
PROVIDER THERE DO THEY HAVE
FAMILY IN THAT COMMUNITY WE HAVE
HEARD OF CASES WHERE A CHILD IS
TRANSFERRED TO THIS YEAR TO BE
IN A COUNTY WHERE CAN DOES
RESIDE.
BUT THEY NEED THAT INTENSIVE
TREATMENT RENDON AND SO THE
ANSWER TO BE IN THAT RATE THE
MEDICAL SERVICES ARE INCLUDED
HOW.
IN IN A DOCTOR TOLD ME SPEAK TO
THIS PROBABLY BETTER AS A BETTER
TOOK UP DEPENDS ON WHETHER THAT
S. HERE TO P. PROVIDES THE
SERVICES IN HOUSE BY.
HIRING CLINICIANS AND OTHERS OR
CONTRACTS WITH THAT COUNTY TO
BRING IN THE COUNTIES CLINICIANS
AND OTHERS EITHER WAY THIS YEAR
T. P. IS BY DEFINITION A
PLACEMENT WHERE A CHILD SHOULD
RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
RIGHT AND FOR NEVADA COUNTY IN
THEIR SITUATION AND DOCTOR HALL
CAN SPEAK TO THIS PROBABLY IS
THEY THE S. R. T. P. IS NOT
QUITE HEARING FROM THE COUNTIES
ARE PLACING.
IN ABOUT AN END THE S. YOUR TO
BE FROM THE MOMENT THAT CHILD
WALKS IN THE DOOR OR PROVIDING
SERVICES.
SO YOU'RE NOT ANSWER MY QUESTION
I WOULD.
SOURCES OF THE EXCHEQUER.
THE SAME SACRAMENTO.
YES THEY SHOULD BUT THERE'S SOME
BACK AND FORTH AND THE ANSWER TO
BE IS PROVIDING SERVICES AND
COSTING THEM MONEY AND SAID IF
YOU'RE TO P..
GOES TO THE COUNTY THAT THEY'RE
IN.
I SAY LOOK YOU GOT TO PAY FOR
THIS LET'S MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THE CHILD ENTITLED AND
TYPICALLY WITH A YEAH WE WE DO.
THIS WHAT CLEAR FIGHT THERE
WOULDN'T BE THAT BACK AND FORTH
AND WHO SHOULD BE PAYING FOR IT
FOR ESTHER TP PLACE WITH SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEKING TO
CLARIFY.
IF THE CHILD IS POISONOUS HERE
TO PETE AND THERE IS A
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER THEN
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
COUNTY OF RESIDENCE IS ONE WHO
SHOULD PAY.
AT THIS ONE BECAUSE YOUR TO YOUR
CONCERN IS BECAUSE YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL YES SO -- IF
I MAY YES SO AS YOU'VE HEARD
FROM SEVERAL PEOPLE AND ALSO
FROM THE LETTER FROM NEVADA
COUNTY AND OTHERS THEY DO SAY
THAT THAT CHALLENGE IS THE
FINANCIAL ISSUE.
AND AS I MENTIONED THAT WAS IN
OUR ORIGINAL LANGUAGE WE SAW WE
PREDICTED THAT THAT WOULD HAPPEN
AND IT WAS REMOVED AT THE
REQUEST OF A DH CS.
AND SO THERE'S STILL AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIX IT THAT WAY.
RATHER THAN A BLANKET EXEMPTION
FOR AS CHAIR TEEPEES I DO WANT
TO CORRECT SOMETHING.
THAT WAS SAID IS IT'S NOT AN
AUTOMATIC -- MOVE ONCE A CHILD
MOVED OUT OF COUNTY WE
INTENTIONALLY BUT THE LANGUAGE
IN THERE THAT HAS TO BE
CONSIDERED ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS.
SO THAT THE CHILD'S PLACEMENT
WORKER WHO KNOWS THE CHILD BEST.
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION WHERE'S
THE CHILD GOING WHAT ARE THE
CHILD'S NEEDS AND IS THIS A
REASON TO EXERCISE ONE OF THE
EXCEPTIONS.
THE EXCEPTIONS ONE OF THEM WAS
EXPLICITLY FOR SHORT TERM
PLACEMENTS IT SAYS THE YOUTH
PLACEMENT IN A COUNTY OTHER THAN
THE COUNTY OF ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION IS EXPECTED TO LAST
FOR SIX MONTHS OR LESS WE PUT
THAT IN THERE FOR US HERE DE
PIECE.
BUT ALL THE OTHERS COULD ALSO BE
APPLIED AND EXERCISE IF THE
COUNTY FEELS THAT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE TO TRANSFER THAT
CHILD.
AND THEY WANT TO TAKE.
SHIP OF THAT CHILD AS FAR AS THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY WERE
SAYING THAT THOSE EXCEPTIONS-THAT THEY'RE SAYING IT'S A
CONCERN WE MOVE THEM BECAUSE
THESE ARE ISSUES CLINICALLY WHEN
A CHILD MOVES WE ALREADY BUILT
THAT INTO THE ORIGINAL BILL SO
WE'RE CONCERNED -- THAT WE'RE
GOING DOWN THIS DIFFERENT
PATHWAY.
ALSO AT THIS BILLS ENACTED WE
WOULD THEN HAVE THREE THINGS
THAT HAPPEN THAT THE PLACEMENT
WORKER WOULD HAVE TO KEEP TRACK
OF IF A CHILD IS MOVED OUT OF
PLACEMENT. SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE IS
STILL IN THE FACT THAT THAT.
IMPACTS AID TO DOCTOR KIDS AP
KIDS THEY GO DOWN ONE PATH WITH
ONE SET OF PAPERWORK.
THIS WOULD CREATE A SECOND.
PATHWAY WITH DIFFERENT PAPERWORK
AND A THIRD PATHWAY WITH
DIFFERENT PAPERWORK FOR THE KIDS
WHO ARE NOT IN EITHER THE
SITUATION SO THE COUNTY IS GOING
TO HAVE.
AN ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN KEEPING
TRACK OF HIS GUN WHERE AND WHAT
PAPERWORK NEEDS TO BE ATTACHED
TO THEM.
OKAY SO.
NOW YOU TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION
SAID EVEN WITH ANY AMENDMENTS.
THAT YOU WOULD STILL STILL SAY
OPPOSE SO IS THERE A PATH TO
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE OKAY YES AND
WE'VE ALREADY STARTED WORKING
WITH THE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
THEY'VE BEEN VERY GRAY EYES.
AND ICE IN THE AUTHORS WILLING
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION I
KNOW SHE USUALLY IS.
IN FACT THE OPPOSITION JUST CAME
IN -- OF A WEEK AGO SO WE IT'S
ALREADY GONE THROUGH.
OUR HOUSE -- WITHOUT OPPOSITION
AND SO WE ABSOLUTELY ENGAGED
ONCE WE RECEIVE TO THE LETTER OF
OPPOSITION AND THIS PARTICULAR
BILL HAS BEEN.
TRIPLE REFERRED.
THERE ARE FEW.
OPPORTUNITIES TO TO GET TO THE
POINT TO WHERE WE WE ALL WILL BE
FINE OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY FOR THE ISSUES
RELATED TO THIS COMMITTEE AND
ALSO I THINK THE GOAL THE BILL
IS ONE THAT I SUPPORT I THINK
IT'S NOT FAIR FOR SMALLER
COUNTIES THAT.
HAVE FACILITIES THAT THEY'RE NOW
ALSO MADE JUST BECAUSE THEY
DECIDE TO BE THE LOCATION OR
DALY OUT AND THE PEOPLE DECIDE
TO OPEN THESE TYPES O
FACILITIES THAT DAY NOW ARE
UNDER FINANCIAL DOES DRESSED SO
WE NEED TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
I APPRECIATE CONTINUE TO WORK
I'M SURE SO IT GOES TO I THINK
HUMAN SERVICES AND OTHER
COMMITTEES.
THE HEALTHY THESE THINGS WILL
WORK OUT CERTAINLY I YOU KNOW
STRESSING SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
AND NOW BEING THAT THOUGH THAT
YOU'LL WORK TOGETHER AND WORK
OUT THE REMAINING ISSUES THAT.
ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A YES CENTER STUDY RESEARCHERS
WANT -- TO THANK YOU ALSO FOR
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY OF THE
HOPES THAT YOU.
HAVE A GOOD MEETING OF THE MINDS
AND A GOOD COMPROMISE COMES INTO.
PLAY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
TO PRESENT THAT.
OKAY SO IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SIR
LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO HUMAN
pCOMMITTEE AND I THINK -- WELL
CHAIR OF HUMAN SERVICES WILL BE
JOINING US SOON -- SHE'S ON THE
COMMITTEE -- SO SECRETARY --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I STONE.
THE RAZA.
DRAWS -- I'D GROVE.
HER TADO.
LEYVA HI LEYVA I'D MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I THE BILL A SIX VOTE SO
WILL BUT THE BILL A CALL THAT'S
ABOUT TO GET VERY MAKING ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU.%
AND WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST ITEM NUMBER.
NINE AB [inaudible]
NINE TWENTY TWO WELCOME.
I REMEMBER MYSELF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS AB NINE TWENTY TO
INTEREST RESEARCH PARTICIPANTS
ARE FAIRLY TREATED BY REMOVING
THE PROHIBITION ON COMPENSATION
FOR WOMEN.
PARTICIPATING IN A DONATION FOR
MEDICAL RESEARCH FORTY SEVEN
OTHER STATES ALREADY ALLOW FOR
COMPENSATION NEW YORK DETERMINED
THAT IT WAS ETHICAL AND APPROACH.
BUT THE WOMEN FOR DONATING --
SITES FOR RESEARCH PURPOSES AND
THAT PAYMENT WOULD BE FUNDED BY
THE STATE.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT WOMEN ARE
TREATED EQUALLY TO ALL OTHER
RESEARCH SUBJECTS ALLOWING THEM
TO ACTIVELY EVALUATE THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN RESEARCH
STUDIES AND TO BE PAID FOR THEIR
TIME TROUBLE.
AND INCONVENIENCE WHEN THEY DO
PARTICIPATE.
WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
EMPOWERING WOMEN TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
OWN HEALTH ARE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT SHOULDN'T STOP WHEN THEY
WHEN IT COMES TO RESEARCH.
NO ONE TAKES A DONATION LIGHTLY
ASSISTED -- SITE PRODUCTION
TAKES TIME A COMMITMENT TO A
RIGID HORRIBLE PROTOCOL AND
DISCOMFORT THAT GOES ALONG WITH
IT.
IT IS A PROCESS THAT I KNOW
FIRST HAND I THINK AT THIS POINT
EVERYBODY.
IN THE BUILDING KNOWS THAT A HUH
THAT -- IF IT WEREN'T FOR IVF I
WOULD NOT HAVE MY DAUGHTER.
ISABELLA AND I AM VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THOSE WOMEN WHO PARTICIPATED
IN RESEARCH.
NOT BEING COMPENSATED HOWEVER
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE HAD TO DO
THAT -- WHEN I FIRST STARTED
REACHED FERTILITY TREATMENTS
THIRTEEN YEARS AGO THE HORMONE
INJECTIONS WERE DIFFERENT THE
PROCESS WITH DIFFERENT -- AND
TODAY HE TREATMENT IS TAILORED
AND MUCH MORE AND MUCH EASIER --
WOMEN GO UNDERGOING CHEMOTHERAPY
NOW CAN PARTICIPATE INFERTILITY
TREATMENTS THERE'S BATTLE CRYO
PRESERVATION OF EVERY.
AND MORE EFFECTIVE PRENATAL CARE
ALL OF THESE ADVANCES IN
TREATMENT ARE DUE TO OUR
ADVANCEMENTS IN RESEARCH.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE LAYERS OF
PROTECTION TO GUARD AGAINST
EXPLOITATION OF DONORS WE HAVE A
THOROUGH LAWS REGULATIONS AND
INFORMED CONSENT FOR TEACH
TEACHERS.
WE HAVE HUMAN SUBJECT RESEARCH
PANELS AND INSTITUTIONAL REVIW
BOARDS THAT ENSURE THAT
PARTICIPANTS ARE SCREENED AND
INFORMED ABOUT THE RISKS.
AND BENEFITS OF TREATMENT THESE
ARE PROCESS THAT WE TRUST TO
PROTECT EVERY OTHER RESEARCH
PARTICIPANT AND A FULLY EXTEND
TO EIGHT DOLLARS.
REMOVING THE BAN ON COMPENSATION
ALLOWED A DONOR'S JUST LIKE
EVERY OTHER RESEARCH PARTICIPANT
TO MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION ON
PARTICIPATION AND TO BE
APPROPRIATELY COMPENSATED.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE MY CELL
CEDARS AND MACROSCOPIC I THINK
THAT'S BEEN CHANGED SO WE NOW I
WHAT THEMSELF ENERGIES.
NINE OKAY SO.
THEN GAS -- THE RULES ARE SIX
MINUTES TOTAL YOU CAN DO LESS IF
YOU WANT TO ADD SO BETWEEN ALL
OF YOU SO WE HAD FIFTY SIX
MINUTES EVEN IF YOU DON'T ENOUGH
TIME FOR THE PEOPLE FOLLOW AFTER.
WILL HAVE TO STOP THERE BUT
AGAIN WELCOME AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SUPPORT
THE REPORT.
DOCTOR PAN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME
IS MARCEL CEDARS AND I'M A BOARD
CERTIFIED REPRODUCTIVE
ENDOCRINOLOGIST AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DIVISION OF REPRODUCTIVE
ENDOCRINOLOGY.
UCSF MEDICAL CENTER.
AS I'VE WORKED WITH PATIENTS
UNDERGOING THESE PROCEDURES FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS I CAN SPEAK
WITH SOME AUTHORITY ABOUT THE
PROCEDURES INVOLVED THE
POTENTIAL RISKS AND HOW TO
ADDITIONALLY THE RESEARCH I DO
ON A DAILY BASIS HAS CLEARED
DIRECT AND POTENTIALLY IMMEDIATE
CLINICAL IMPLICATION TO IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FR MY
PATIENTS.
AND I KNOW THAT WITHOUT
COMPENSATION WE CANNOT OBTAIN
THE SITES TO DO FURTHER RESEARCH
THAT ONE MID DAY MAY IMPROVE
CARE FOR WOMEN.
OVARIAN STIMULATION OVERSIGHT
RETRIEVAL ARE TIME CONSUMING AND
ARDUOUS THE ETHICS COMMITTEE OF
BOTH THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE AND THE
INTERNATIONAL SOCIETY FOR STEM
CELL RESEARCH.
HAVE CONSIDERED THE ISSUE OF
COMPENSATION FOR DONOR AND HAVE
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
COMPENSATION IS WARRANTED AND
ETHICAL.
OUR ANALYSIS OF COMPENSATION
DOES NOT CHANGE ON THE END USE
OF THE DONATION WHETHER TO HELP
CREATE A FAMILY OR FOR RESEARCH.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA COMPENSATION
IS PROHIBITED ESSENTIALLY
CLOSING OFF RESEARCH WHICH COULD
OTHERWISE BE DONE BY THE WORLD
RENOWNED SCIENTIST IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE ONE OF ONLY ONE OF THREE
STATES THAT HAVE SUCH A BAN.
ACCORDING TO FEDERAL RESEARCH
GUIDELINES ALL RESEARCH
PARTICIPANTS MUST BECOME. FOR
THEIR TIME TROUBLE AND
INCONVENIENCE THEM AND FROM
RESEARCH ADDITIONALLY ALL
RESEARCH INVOLVING HUMAN
SUBJECTS IS REVIEWED BY AN
INSTITUTIONAL REVIEW BOARD WHOSE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY IS TO
PROTECT RESEARCH PARTICIPANTS
FROM UNDUE RISK AND INFLUENCE.
IT IS ALSO THE JOB OF THESE
BOARDS TO SET COMPENSATION FOR
RESEARCH SUBJECTS THERE'S NO
REASON THIS WELL ESTABLISHED
POLICY OF OVERSIGHT SHOULD BE
DIFFERENT FOR WOMEN WHO DONATE --
SITES TO SCIENCE.
FURTHER ANY RESEARCH THAT
INVOLVES REPRODUCTIVE TISSUES
MUST UNDERGO AN ADDITIONAL LEVEL
OF REVIEW BY A SEPARATE
COMMITTEE.
THAT IS COMPOSED OF SCIENTISTS
ETHICISTS AND LAY PERSONS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE SOLE
REASON THE NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF
SCIENCE DID NOT RECOMMEND
COMPENSATION IN THE ORIGINAL
GUIDELINES WAS OUT OF POLITICAL
EXPEDIENCY BECAUSE OF CONCERN
FOR CREATING ADDITIONAL
CONTROVERSY OVER A LOT OF ROUND
THE INITIAL EMBRYO STEM CELL
RESEARCH.
THE SAME CONCERN EXTENDED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STEM CELL RESEARCH
INSTITUTE.
EVERY MEDICAL PROCEDURE HAS A
LEVEL OF RISK OVARIAN%
STIMULATION RETRIEVAL AS WAS
MENTIONED OUR STANDARD
PROCEDURES USED FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS.
LAST YEAR THIS PROCEDURE WAS
PERFORMED IN OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION WOMEN GLOBALLY.
XIN INDUCTION STRATEGIES ARE
THOUGHT TO ALL BUT ELIMINATE THE
RISK OF OVARIAN STIMULATION
SYNDROME AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
RETRIEVING TEN TO TWENTY AEGS
YIELD OPTIMAL EGG QUALITY BOTH
FOR RESEARCH INFERTILITY
PURPOSES.
STUDIES REGARDING CANCER RISK
HAVE BEEN LARGELY REASSURING.
AND THERE ARE NO SIGNIFICANT
INCREASED RISK FOR BREAST
OVARIAN OR UTERINE CANCER.
LONGER TERM FOLLOW UP IS
OBVIOUSLY DESIRABLE AND IS PART
OF THE MOTIVATION BEHIND A JOINT
EFFORT BETWEEN THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE
AND THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH.
THE FUND A VOLUNTARY REGISTRY.
LET ME JUST ALSO ADD -- THAT
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED ABOUT
LOW INCOME WOMEN WOMEN OF COLOR
IN IMMIGRANTS BEING TARGETED FOR
THIS RESEARCH.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST
THAT THAT WOULD BE THE CASE AND
IN FACT THE TWO STATES CURRENTLY
ENROLLING IN ARGAN IN NEW YORK.
HAVE HAD DONORS WHO WERE
PRIMARILY CAUCASIAN AND WITH A
COLLEGE EDUCATION THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT RECRUITMENT --
TARGETING OF UNDER RERESENTED
MINORITY YOU'RE LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS AWARD THAT THE
PRINCIPLES OF CONSENT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT.
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT THIS COMMITTEE RECOGNIZE
THE WELL ESTABLISHED PRINCIPLE
IN SOCIETY THAT WHEN SOCIETY
BENEFITS FROM RESEARCH --
COMPENSATION TO THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE AND CONTRIBUTE AND
WE OWE THESE WOMEN THE
PERSPECTIVE KNOWLEDGE THEY ARE
CAPABLE OF WEIGHING THE RISKS
ARE PARTICIPATION AND THE
REWARDS OF CONTRIBUTING TO
SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE.
I THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE.
I THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY.
IN MAKING IT EASIER TO ACCESS TO
MAX FOR RESEARCH PURPOSES MY
NAME IS BANKS TERRACE AND I AM A
TRAINED CAN CLAIM RELIGIOUS.
I ALSO HAVE A PC FOR COMMISSION
ADVERSITY AND QUALIFIED RESEARCH
REPRODUCTIVE.
MEDICINE. THIRTY THREE TO TRY TO
BIOLOGY -- I HAVE ROOTED FOR THE
PATIENTS AND A DONOR'S
UNDERGOING ASSISTED REPRODUCTIVE
TECHNOLOGIES.
BEAU HAS AN EMBRYOLOGIST AS A
RESEARCHER BY THE PROCEDURES
INVOLVED OR LONG CAN BE
STRESSFUL AND IS THAT IT ANY
OTHER MEDICAL.
MEDICAL PROCEDURE I HAVE THEIR
RISK.
I BELIEVE THERE IS BIG POTENTIAL
AB OR WE CAN MAKE ASSIST
REPRODUCTIVE TECHNOLOGY IS MUCH
MORE PATIENT FRIENDLY MUCH SAFER
AND MUCH MORE AFFORDABLE FOR TO
BE ACCESSIBLE FOR MANY MILLIONS
OF WOMEN.
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO SHARE WITH YOU BY I THINK IT
OFTEN JUST LAW IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THAT -- OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CASES OF IN VITRO
FERTILIZATION OCCURRING PER YEAR
IN THE UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW.
COSTING OVER.
FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER PROCEDURE
USUALLY BEING PAID DIRECTLY BY
THE PATIENT.
RIGHT NOW PATIENTS NEEDS TO
INJECT THEMSELVES THAN TO
FIFTEEN HOME INJECTIONS BEFORE
THEY ARE ABLE TO DO THE
PROCEDURE ITSELF.
A DECENT INJECTIONS CAN BE
UNPLEASANT I RESULTING IN
UNUSUALLY UNCOMFORTABLE BLOATING
AND SWELLING.
WHY THE FREQUENCY FOR VERY HIGH
PROCEED STIMULATION SYNDROME HAS
BEEN ACCUSED -- I DO TO ADVANCE
IN THE FIELD THERE IS PROMISING
RESEARCH WHERE WE CAN ELIMINATE
THESE RISKS ALTOGETHER.
OR A CONSTANT MEDICAL HEALTH
INCLUDING THE VERY FIRST IVF BE
BORN OVER FORTY YEARS AGO.
HAVE BEEN THE RESULT OF
BREAKTHROUGHS IN SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH.
THERE IS STILL SO MUCH WE CAN DO
A FOR WOMEN AND COUPLES SITTING
FOR THROUGH THE TREATMENT
RESEARCH IS CURRENTLY BEING SOLD
IN CALIFORNIA -- DUE TO LACK OF
COMPENSATION FOR PARTICIPANTS.
TO USE MY ORGANIZATION AS AN
EXAMPLE I AM BELIEVE SCIENTISTS
AT A RESEARCH ORGANIZATION THIS
IS TRYING TO DEVELOP.
A WASTED AT WOMEN DO NOT NEED
WOMAN INJECTIONS -- I WOULD LIKE
THANK YOU.
FOR LISTENING TO MY TESTIMONY
AND I WILL SELECT THE STATE AT
AS MANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS BOTH
RESEARCH PUBLIC -- AND ACADEMIC.
RESEARCH CAN LEAVE CALIFORNIA BE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE SHOES.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME OR THE
SHANNON SMITH PELLY REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE WHERE THE
SPONSORS OF THIS AND I'M
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORT.
MY COLLEAGUES AT ALL
REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
AND CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN THIS TO
SHIP NINE IN SUPPORT OKAY THANK
YOU.
RIGHT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
A SAYING NONE -- QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THIS BEEN MOTION MOVED AVAIL US
ARE DRUG.
YES -- I KNOW YOU YOU MENTIONED.
ONE OF THE CONCERNS SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE LINE THAT WAS RAISED
AS THE IMPACT ON WELL WOMEN OF
COLOR -- I WOULD ADD TO THAT
POOR WOMEN -- ARE THERE ANY I'M
NOT SUGGESTING AMENDMENT I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT HOWEVER ARE
THERE ANY.
MEASURES NOW OR DATA SYSTEMS NOW
THEY COLLECT THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT WE DON'T WAIT.
UNTIL AND RAIN IF THERE EVER WAS
AN ABUSEOF THAT PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED POOR WOMEN AND WOMEN OF
COLOR.
SO THAT THIS DOESN'T BECOME A
AND IT IS STILL A COUPLE THINGS.
ONE WE HAVE A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
ON THE BILL SO THAT IF THERE IS
AN ISSUE THAT WE WILL BE A GREAT.
REST BUT FURTHERMORE WE FOUND
STUDIES FROM COLUMBIA BOTH THE
NEW YORK AND CITIES IN OREGON
SHOWING THAT THE BULK OF THE
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING OVER 454%
IN.
NEW YORK OR CAR OCCASION AND 86%
AND HARD AGAIN WERE CAUCASIAN --
THIS IS ALL IT'S IT IT'S A LONG
PROTOCOL OF THIS IS NOT A SHORT
THIS IS NOT A SHORT BURST OF
MONEY THIS IS NOT A MAN GOING IN.
FOR A HOWEVER WE SAID TWENTY
MINUTES BUT WHATEVER HOWEVER
LONG.
GOING INTO DO THEIR PORTION THIS
IS AN ARDUOUS PROCESS THAT --
TAKES TIME.
OUT OF YOUR SCHEDULE AND OUT OF
YOUR OUT OF YOUR LIFE AND SO IT
IS NOT THIS IS NOT A QUICK BURST
OF MONEY AND I THINK THAT THAT.
THE CONCERN FROM THOSE WHO ARE --
LESS EDUCATED ON HOW THIS
PROCESS REALLY WORKS.
MIGHT I ALSO ADD THAT ALL OF THE
INSTITUTIONAL READ REVIEW BOARDS
COLLECT DATA ON RACE AND
ETHNICITY OF PATIENTS --
SUBJECTS -- IT DOESN'T COLLECT
FINANCIAL INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
THOSE OF US WHO DO RESEARCH CAN
DO BUT THEY DO COLLECT RACIAL
AND ETHNIC INFORMATION AND WE
HAVE TO SUBMIT.
CONSENT FORMS AND THOSE WHO'VE
CONSENTED AND THAT KIND OF
SUMMARY DATA ON A YEARLY BASIS.
WELL I WOULD ESPECIALLY IF.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A A SUNSET I
WOULD REALLY URGE THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN TOO MANY TIMES -- THAT
POOR WOMEN AND WOMEN OF COLOR
ARE ABUSED -- IN MEDICINE AND
ITS SYSTEMIC -- SO IT REALLY YOU
KNOW WATCH OUT FOR THAT RAIN AND
MAYBE GET YOU KNOW ON A
VOLUNTARY SINCE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MAKE AN AMENDMENT.
BUT BEGIN TO GATHER THAT VERY
EXPLICIT INFORMATION BECAUSE I
THINK INCOME LEVELS ARE.
ALSO HIGHLY IMPORTANT AND NOT
JUST -- ETHNICITY THANK YOU AND
I WOULD AGREE IT'S A VITAL
QUESTION.
SENATE MITCHELL.
I WOULD JUST THINK THAT THAT I'M
ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE OF THE
ARGUMENT -- TO MY COLLEAGUE I
THINK IN THIS INSTANCE -- WOMEN
OF COLOR AND POOR WOMEN -- HAVE
THE RIGHT TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR OWN BODIES AS WELL
AND SO WHAT WE DON'T WANT THEM
EXPLOIT IT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- ALL DESCRIPTORS ARE
WRITTEN IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES SO
EVERYONE CAN BENEFIT FROM TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM -- I I
KNOW SOME OF THE THE WE PAY TO
WRITE SOCIAIS SINCE I TYPICALLY
LINE WITH -- LATINAS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND OTHERS
ARE IN OPPOSITION BUT I THINK I
ALSO DON'T WANT TO CREATE.
A A EIGHT DIFFERENT EXPECTATION
WOMEN OF COLOR AND POOR WOMEN
HAVE THE RIGHT.
ALL THEIR BODIES JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE I THINK THAT'S
THE PERSPECTIVE THAT I WOULD
TAKE ON IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THIS -- AND
NOT ASSUME THAT POOR WOMEN ARE
GOING -- TO EXCESSIVELY UTILIZE
IT TO MAKE MONEY OFF OF THEIR
ACHES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY SO I I
JUST -- THAT WHAT THAT SOME
NUMBER GOING THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
KNOW THIS.
TOPIC THAT WAS INVOLVED IN A
DEBATE IN THIS INTERNALLY WITHIN
THE MEDICAL PROFESSION.
ABOUT THE SAY THAT CERTAINLY THE
ISSUES OF EXPLOITATION WERE
BROUGHT UP BUT I ALSO WANT TO
BRING -- POINT OUT THAT -- AND
ONE REASONS I'D WANT TO LOOK AT
THE DATA IS ACTUALLY THE OTHER
WAY AROUND -- TO OFF AND WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH REPRESENTATION
BY WOMEN OVERALL THOUGH
CERTAINLY THIS RESEARCH ALLEN
WE'VE SEEN REPORTS ABOUT THAT.
AND ALSO -- SURREALISM MCCARTY
MYSELF.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THE RESEARCH IS
ONLY DONE IN NON MINORITY
POPULATIONS AND THEN APPLY TO US
THEN THAT'S PROBLEMATIC AS WELL
SO -- THERE'S A REASON YOU HAVE
AN I. R. B. HAD -- INSTITUTIONAL
REVIEW BOARD -- AS A RESEARCHER
IT HAD TO HAVE MY A TUG OF WAR
WITH THE I. R. B. ABOUT WHAT
THEY WANT AND DEMAND AND
ACTUALLY THEY CAN REQUIRE I MEAN
WE CAN I CAN ARGUE BUT THEY WILL
REQUIRE. TO BE SURE THAT THAT IS.
TODAY PERFECT NO -- BUT
CERTAINLY THEY'RE VERY THOROUGH
AND I KNOW THAT EVERY RB I EVER
WORKED WITH DEFINITELY IT IS
FIGHTING FOR ON BEHALF OF THE
PATIENT I MEAN THAT MAY NOT
ALWAYS AGREE WITH THEM BUT
THEY'RE DEFINITELY LIKE OKAY
FROM THE BASES PERSPECTIVE THIS
IS WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
PROTECT.
THEM AND SO I THINK THAT THAT
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZING WHO REALLY
WANT TO DO IS INSURE WOMEN WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS RESEARCH
VITAL IMPORTANT RESEARCH.
THATTHEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE SAME.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SAME
PROTECTIONS IN THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS ANY OTHER TYPE
OF RESEARCH AND THAT'S WHY I
REALLY APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS
BILL.
OKAY SO THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED IN
THIS ON THE COMMENTS -- SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I I WOULD JUST
I WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS --
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T WANT ANYONE --
UNFAIRLY IT LEFT OUT OR BROUGHT
INTO ANY STUDY SITUATION AS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN I HAVE
BEEN THE GREAT BENEFIT OF THE
FACT THAT I'M MULTI NATIONAL
GROUP OF FOLKS HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN THIS RESEARCH.
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'D TIME IN
OUR COUNTRY WERE WOMEN'S RIGHTS
AND WHAT WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE AND
OUR ABILITY TO CHOOSE A SOMEONE --
QUESTION TO UNDERMINE THAT IN
ANYWAY -- WOULD BE A GREAT
INJUSTICE WE WE COMPENSATE OTHER
RESEARCH RESEARCH PARTICIPANTS
THERE'S NO REASON WOMAN SHOULD
BE LEFT OUT OF THAT -- AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND
I WILL.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THE MOTION IS --
TO TO GO STRAIGHT TO THE FLORIDA
IT'S BEEN SECONDED BY CENTER
LEYVA A SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
PAN HI PAN AYE STONE.
STONE NO DORADO.
DRUGS SO I GROW [inaudible]
HER TADO.
LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
REVEALED BY.
HI.
SIX ONE OKAY THAT BILL IS -- HAS
THE SIX SIX ONE IT'S OUT.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH.
RIGHT -- THANK YOU NEXT ITEM IS
ACTUALLY THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER --
MITCHELL RIGHT -- AND SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE
CONSENT TO ACTUALLY READ OFF
WHAT'S ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
JUST FOR THE RECORD -- WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB -- EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER
WICKS -- ITEM NUMBER. TWELVE AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO BY SOME
MEMBER OF OUR CON.
THAT NUMBER THIRTEEN AB AT NO
TWO WHICH IS A HEALTH HEALTH
COMMITTEE BILL ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE BILL AND I AND NUMBER
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHTEEN OH
THREE WHICH IS ALSO HEALTH
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE BILL
SO IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL -- SO DO PASSED WITH A
MAN OUTSIDE.
THEY ARE DATED BECAUSE THAT GUY
YOURSELF AND ALSO IT I DON'T --
THAT WOULD BE PROOF WITH
AMENDMENTS -- THE OTHER ITEMS
ARE IS AS SO SEPARATE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL PAN HI PAN AYE
STONE.
STONE I'D DORADO DRAWS A AYE
GROVE.
GROVE I HER TADO HER TITLE AYE
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
THANK FUNDING I RUBIO HI RUBIO I
OKAY THE SEND CALORIES OUT NINE
ZERO ALRIGHT SO LET'S GO BACK
AND FOR ALL THE AND MEMBERS ARE
ON CALL SO WE JUST GO AND FOLLOW
ORDER NUMBER SO STARTING WITH --
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO TWENTY
EIGHT BY SOME NUMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AMENDED TO BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
AS A SRAIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE I'D DORADO DRUGS -- I FOR
TADO.
LEYVA LIVE AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING THANK
MONNING AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
HI.
EIGHT OKAY SO THAT BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO OKAY NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME EVER CERVANTES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE SIX OF THESE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE I TORONTO I HER TATO. FOR
TITLE I LEYVA LIVE AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING I'VE RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO OKAY NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
BY SOME A RADIUS.
AND WITH THE CHAIR OF VOTING I
AND MOTIONS TO PASS THE HUMAN
SERVICES SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
NO NO GROWTH [inaudible]
HER TADO.
I HER TITLE I OKAY THAT FILLS
OUT.
SEVEN ONE A NEXT BILL IS ITEM
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY EIGHT BY SOME
MEMBER OF GRAY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS GERMANY ICICLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THAT SOME
MEMBERS STONE.
STONE AYE DORADO.
DRAWS -- I HER TADO FOR TITLE I
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING THANK
MONNING AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I THAT BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO A NEXT ITEM IS ITEM.
NICE TENNIS SO IT'S IT'S ITEM
NUMBER.
TEN BY SOME MEMBER OF DONALD THE
ONE THAT.
BACK FOR ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS --
SET AND THE MOTIONS TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO APPROPRIATIONS THE
CHAIR VOTING I SIX A PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE NO GROWTH [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
THE FOURTEEN TEN FOURTEEN THIS
IS THE ONE THAT WE HEARD LAST
WEEK IN ADDITIONAL MEN'S.
MITCHELL AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN ONE
OKAY.
OKAY WELL THAT CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA OF THE SAID HEARING OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
FOR THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THE WALL